einige von euch haben sicher mitbekommen
großbritannien wurde wieder ein paar mit
dem nervengift namens novacek vergiftet
die frau ist nun gestorben
verantwortlich dafür ist dieselbe
substanz wie bei dem anschlag auf den
doppelagenten street war vor einigen
monaten feststeht nowak ist hochgiftig
und tödlicher als das nervengift sarin
niemand weiß wie es überhaupt nach
großbritannien kam also ein
hochaktuelles thema mit vielen offenen
fragen was ist das genau für ein stoff
wie wirkte auf den menschlichen körper
und besteht auch die gefahr für die
gesamte öffentlichkeit hierbei klick zum
science fiction jetzt die antworten
herzlich willkommen
es dauerte nur wenige stunden und dann
stand auch hier sicher fest der 45
jährige mann und seine 44 jährige frau
die mann bewusstlos in einem wohnhaus in
der nähe des britischen sainsbury
gefunden hatte waren mit dem nervengift
nowak vergiftet worden das passiert über
die atemwege und manchmal auch über die
haut oder schleimhäute im menschlichen
körper blockiert nowaczyk ein enzym das
eigentlich für die kommunikation
zwischen nerven und muskeln zuständig
ist die folge eine überstrapazierung der
muskeln was sich in krämpfen äußert mann
leidet an kopfschmerzen durchfall
übelkeit und atemnot und im schlimmsten
fall kann es auch zu herzstillstand und
bewusstlosigkeit kommen das gehirn kann
durch den sauerstoffmangel geschädigt
werden mit langzeitfolgen ob man als
opfer eines solchen anschlages überlebt
hängt stark davon ab wie schnell ein
gegenmittel gegeben werden kann dass das
blockierte enzymen wieder reaktiviert
die beiden opfer aus salzburg jedenfalls
schritt lange zeit in lebensgefahr die
44 jährige frau ist nun gestorben und
die behörden in großbritannien ermitteln
nun wegen mordes
sofort werden erinnerungen wach an
anfang märz vielleicht hatte er es
mitbekommen damals war ein anschlag mit
diesem nervengift auf den ehemaligen
russischen doppelagenten sergej skripal
und seine tochter julia verübt worden
großbritannien und auch viele andere
politiker gaben damals russland die
schuld liegt ja auch eigentlich auf der
hand unabhängig davon kämpften die
beiden damals wochenlang im krankenhaus
um ihr leben jetzt also der zweite
mysteriöse fall und das ganze in der
nähe des wohnorts der ersten opfer
ob das nervengift aus derselben charge
stammt wie bei den skript als ist
allerdings noch nicht bekannt fest steht
die so video nun hat die naughty dog
gifte in den 70er und 80er jahren
entwickelt gegen ende des kalten krieges
und niemand sollte davon wissen um
internationale abkommen zu waffen zu
umgehen sollten ovi job so entwickelt
werden dass diese substanz nicht
nachweisbar ist
aktionen kamen dann anfang der 90er
jahre doch ans liegt aber nur bei zwei
chemiker davon berichtet nun noch immer
lassen sich diese stoffe nicht so
einfach nachweisen wie es bei anderen
nervengifte der fall ist wie
beispielsweise sarin und vx zwei
hochgiftigen substanzen übrigens wie
auch durch bloßen kontakt und das
einatmen innerhalb von minuten zum tod
führen nervengifte heißen sie deshalb
weil sie das nervensystem wie new york
leben und so diverse körperfunktion
erheblich stören und so lahm legen so
dass die opfer sehr schnell sterben doch
nur wie doc hat es in sich die gesamte
gift gruppe besteht aus etwa 100
verschiedenen stoff varianten von denen
manche bis zu acht mal tödlicher sein
sollen als das nervengift vx sie sind
sehr feine bruder und wirken den
menschlichen körper langsamer im
gegensatz zu vielen anderen nervengifte
die als kampfstoffe oder waffen
eingesetzt werden das sind meistens
farblose flüssigkeit in den halb weniger
minuten zum tod führen kurioserweise
wird das gift nowak aus zwei stoffen
hergestellt die an sich nicht giftig
sind seine tödliche wirkung entsteht
erst bei der kombination bei der
grundstufe werden nicht besonders streng
kontrolliert und können theoretisch
leicht geschafft werden expertinnen und
experten sind der ansicht dass die
kombination der beiden stoffe allerdings
für einen laien nicht möglich sei dafür
sei ein gewisses fachwissen notwendig
dass beispielsweise geübte chemiker und
chemikerinnen haben so wird behauptet
andere experten und experten glauben
dass nur staaten dazu fähig sein denn
schließlich seien labore mit sehr hohen
sicherheitsvorschriften voraussetzungen
jetzt bei dem aktuellen zweiten fall
sind sich die britischen behörden
relativ sicher dass die beiden opfer nur
zufällig mit dem giftstoff in berührung
haben und sie eben nicht gezielt mit
naughty dog angegriffen wurden dennoch
steht die große frage im raum wie sie
sich kontaminiert haben können nach dem
anschlag am skript wahl wurden neun
bereiche in der region dekontaminiert
für millionenbeträge an seiner türklinke
hatte man im frühling die höchste note
job konzentration festgestellt doch wie
diese genau kontaminiert worden war
also wie das gift dorthin kamen das weiß
man nicht ein behältnis oder ähnliches
wurde bisher nicht gefunden
damals wie heute sehen die
doch keine große gefahr für die
bevölkerung doch gegen das mulmige
gefühl dass bei vielen briten bleibt
hilft diese einschätzung nicht offen
bleiben weitere fragen woher stammt die
substanz und wo wurde sie hergestellt
mit den heutigen labormethoden ist es
möglich durch verbliebene reste
rückschlüsse darauf herzustellen denn
die staaten wissen etwa durch welche
prozesse die unterschiedlichen
regierungen solche substanzen herstellen
russland hat ja ende des letzten jahres
2017 bekannt gegeben
an der letzten gv waffen zerstört zu
haben das nachzuprüfen ja das ist jedoch
reichlich schwer die ermittlungsbehörden
arbeiten aber intensiv daran
herauszufinden woher das gift stammt
wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollen dann
endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er
die kaputte hamburg sie auf youtube und
verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen andern vom neues video
täglich und garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal pixum social and media
abonnieren da gibt es immer das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier
klicken
aber natürlich nicht die genau die
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken nieper das
gefährlichste virus der welt breitet
sich in indien aus bis dann bleibt dran